TAMZIN TAYLOR: My
name is Tamzin,
and I'm a partner development
manager for the UK and Nordics.
Now, I've been involved in
mobile content since 2001,
and I can tell you I'm
so excited about how
well the industry's grown.
And it just makes
me really happy
to see the rich
potential that we're
building for partners
like yourself
in the Android ecosystem.
So I think we've heard a
lot today about monetization
and improvement.
Monetization is not just
about pricing, obviously.
I think we've heard today
some great tips from people,
like Illya Michael,
about quality
being the cornerstone of
success, things like design,
using the platform
tools, like beta testing
and staged rollouts.
And if any of you
attended Mateo's session
on engagement techniques,
it was absolutely fantastic.
So things around
understanding your users
to drive engagement retention
and understand lifetime value.
So-- let's see, is
that-- so let's look
at the growing opportunity now.
I know that we touched on
this earlier in the day.
So in Mark's welcome
speech, he gave you an idea
of the growth of the Android.
And I guess, what I'm
trying to get across here
is there is a massive
capacity to earn,
and there are increasingly
more ways for people to pay.
I know we touched
on this earlier,
but local forms of payment,
like direct carrier billing,
gift cards, and PayPal, are
opening up new audiences
for you to target.
And I've actually
seen with my own eyes,
when we launched a new form
of payment in New Zealand,
we actually got new users
in incremental sales.
So we're actually opening
up new audiences for you
to sell to in New Zealand.
They buy content.
So we're seeing
great success today.
Just a couple of key pointers.
We've unlocked the
domestic market of Germany.
When we launched a
new local payment,
we saw a 70% growth in
year-on-year buy growth.
And one thing I'd like to call
out as well is just to show you
that the capacity of
play to earn money.
We had 38% year-on-year
growth from primarily
international sales.
So given this increasingly
global market,
how should you price
your quality application?
Note, I said quality, because
you've heard everything today.
And I know you're going to
go out and implement it.
So the global market is
ready for your products.
Your application is built.
You've improved the design.
You're using all the
platform features.
Pricing for globalization
is very important.
And my esteemed
colleague, Yashi,
who's getting
mocked up somewhere,
is talking after
me about go global.
So he'll tell you
more information
about other factors on that.
But I'd like to start
with a few key points
on setting and
managing your prices.
Now, you may say to me, ah,
Tamzin, that's common sense.
And some of it is
common sense, but you'd
be surprised how few developers
actually implement it.
So I'm going to call them
out today really quickly,
and you can tell me to
sit down if it's boring.
And these will include matching
the model to the market,
taking into consideration
purchasing power parity, which
is how much consumers
can afford, local price
preferences, as
[INAUDIBLE] mentioned,
will be the $0.99 not going
well in Japan, audience
segmentation, and just checking
in on your pricing strategy
regularly.
So to kick things off, matching
the model to the market.
So we know that there are
multiple ways to bill customers
at Google Play-- free, freemium,
premium, subscriptions,
et cetera.
So it's really
important to make sure
that you carve out a
pricing model that's
going to meet the cultural
and economic factors
within that country.
So if you were
targeting a country that
has very high prepaid
penetration and perhaps very
low credit card
penetration, you might
want to consider more
transactional type of payment
models, like in-app
billing or premium,
to take into account perhaps
the less regular cadence
of top apps they might
have on their phone.
And of course, the model should
support the value proposition
of your content.
For example, if you have
a subscription offering,
make sure that the content
or the functionality
is refreshed regularly, or
that the user has a reason
to go back into it daily
to get value out of it.
Hands up here.
Who has heard about the minimum
price reduction in India?
Excellent.
And who actually did lower
their price and go into India?
Fantastic.
If I had a fruit basket,
I'd give you one.
So what we did recently is
we lowered the minimum price
that you could charge out on
the Google Play Store in India,
from 50 rupees to 10 rupees.
Now, I guess, to put it in
context, a can of Coke in India
costs about 10 rupees,
but it costs $1 in the US.
So OK, that's fine.
That's fine.
But we know that, actually,
$1 US equals 66 rupees, if you
take yesterday's exchange rate.
So then, hang on a sec.
So they're charging 10 rupees in
India, but 66 rupees in the US?
So what we're seeing
here is a clear example
of Coca-Cola basically pricing
to what the market can afford,
purchasing power parity.
So that's kind of what
we were trying to get at,
is we know there's a
market exchange rate,
but there's always a soft
consumer price that kind of
will get you more conversions.
So some results after we
launched the minimum price was
that, after four
weeks, we had 560
titles across 220
developers that
changed their prices for India.
So you're one of 220, sir.
And as a result, we've seen
an 800% increase in revenue.
I mean, that's outstanding.
And the great thing that
we like to point out
is-- are you're based in
India, or the UK, or EMIR?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
TAMZIN TAYLOR: UK.
So you're one of the 75%
of those 220 developers
who actually changed their
prices for the Indian market.
So it's a very international
market we're happy to see.
One call-out I'd
like to make is Nova.
So Nova do a browser launcher.
And they originally
were priced at $499 USD,
which equated to
about 325 rupees.
That's like 32 cans of Coke.
So they took advantage
of this offer,
and they changed their price,
I believe, to 15 rupees.
And you can see
the impact there,
a 136% increase in orders
and 27% increase in revenue.
So again, a very
happy developer.
Oh, and it's live.
So if you haven't done
it yet, and you still
want to target India,
you should get in there.
And we know that many
of our top partners
are doing their own testing
on prices across the world.
One amazing learning
application did some ABCD tests
in the US and Russia recently.
And they found
that, for the USA,
they tested four
different price points,
and the optimal one was 23%
lower than their original.
And that generated them
95% increase in conversion
and 52% increase in RPU.
Similarly, for the Russian
tests, it was a 12% drop.
You can see the stats there.
So I guess the caveat here
is, don't take these price
drops as what you should do,
because your content is unique,
and your markets will
be the ones you choose.
But if you can find a way
to test different prices
across your markets,
we recommend
this is the way to
find the optimal price
to help you increase conversion
and gain incremental revenue.
Now again, we touched
on this earlier a bit.
So you know, I'm from
Australia, not New Zealand.
And one thing that
really annoyed me is I'd
go into the Play Store and
I'd go in looking for an app,
and then find the app.
Fantastic.
And it would say, you'll
be charged $1.16, or $3.74.
I'm like-- [GROANS].
I kind of feel
like the developer
doesn't care about me.
And we know from what
we discussed before,
that in Japan, they prefer
whole figures, like 700 yen,
not 701 yen.
So in the Developer
Console, we actually
enable you to
customize the prices
of your in-app SKUs, or premium
prices, or subscriptions,
by country.
And the great thing about
that is you do it once,
and then we will, on
our side, convert that
to the local currency
so that, when
users see an optimized price
and a value offering that
works for them,
they're more likely to,
if they like the content,
to make the purchase.
And who here attended Mateo's
talk about engagement?
Excellent.
OK, so this may seem
familiar territory,
but I just want to
touch on it again,
because it's so important.
So we know that users
are not homogeneous.
It's best practice to know
who your customers are,
what their behaviors are
like, and what they'll pay.
If you can do this, you can
carve out different strategies
to help them along
the purchase journey.
Mateo talked a lot
about Google Analytics,
but any analytics are important.
And really, if
you can find a way
to differentiate your
segments to then identify
who are the spenders and who
are the non-spenders, who
are the engaged and who
are the not engaged,
and then present them
different offers,
we've seen good success.
So Wish, for example,
used this system.
And for those of you who
weren't in Mateo's speech,
Wish basically created
different product offers,
so cheaper offers for
less engaged users,
and more expensive product
offers for the more engaged,
and saw a 10% increase
in conversion.
Anyone sell to Russia here?
A few.
So you're probably
familiar with this graph.
But essentially, one of
the last best practice
pricing initiatives is really
to check in on your pricing
regularly.
For example, if a
developer set their price
in 2014, February 1st, and
didn't change it for a year,
they would have seen
their gross revenue
from Russia nearly half,
because of the four exchanges.
So we recommend going in
and checking your pricing
regularly, so you can see where
you are versus your competitors
and versus the exchange
rate fluctuations.
So we've just touched on
all the best practices.
And I'm running slightly late,
so I'm going to continue on.
The running theme here is that
not all users are the same.
They've got different
price sensitivities
and different needs.
So how can you deal
with this, when you're
talking about a global market?
So I'm going to
touch now on AdMob,
and then give you a bit
of an update on what we're
doing with subscriptions.
Clicker, come on.
OK.
So anyone here use AdMob?
And I won't be
upset if you don't.
Great.
Excellent.
So AdMob, for those of
you who don't use it,
is our industry leading
ads and mediation platform.
It's earned over 650,000
developers over $1 billion
in the last two years.
And as you can see here,
the growth statistics
are very, very impressive.
And it tells us a
bit AdMob, of course,
but it really tells us
something about the ecosystem.
And what it says
is that advertising
is a very important part
of that monetization,
and it's growing each year.
In fact, Gartner
predicted-- and this
is Gartner-- that
by 2017, they'll
be nearly 270 billion
app downloads.
And the majority of these they
think will be free in premium,
or freemium.
And with the growth in free
and freemium, of course,
is the growth in
mobile advertising.
So we talked about consumers
differing between markets
because of disposable income
and cultural differences,
but we believe
that you shouldn't
be forced to choose
between only monetising
through in-app advertising,
or through ads.
But to date, we haven't
really given developers
the option, until now.
So AdMob actually is
trying to help you find
the right monetization model.
It feeds in the opportunities,
processes the information,
looks at your ads,
your app, your users,
and your advertisers,
and then will deliver
the right experience to them.
So what this means,
in a nutshell,
is that you can have
it set up in your apps
so that either users,
who we identify
being as high spenders,
will see an in-app purchase
ad for your product.
And those who we identify
as being low spenders,
will simply see an AdMob ad or
one of your third-party ads.
In this way, we try and help
you monetize all users, not just
the high spenders,
and not just those who
are not going to spend.
So this is another example of
a tool called, Audience Builder
within AdMob that
allows you then to go in
and, I guess, fiddle and
create deeper segmentation
for your audiences, to
give them different offers.
And one example here is that,
if you do have very high paying
users, you might not want
to show them ads at all.
And the AdMob platform
allows you to do this.
So in-app purchasing and adds,
two great ways to make money.
But there's a third one.
Who here likes
recurring revenue?
Excellent.
So let me tell you a
bit about subscriptions.
Another question for the team.
Who has a Netflix account?
Fantastic.
Who's got a mobile plan?
So you can see here
that subscriptions
are tried and tested model
that people are quite used to
and they like.
From a user's perspective, it's
great, because then there's
no bill shock.
Once you've signed
up, you can expect
to get free access to
the content, ongoing.
Furthermore, it builds
trust in the brand.
For developers,
recurring revenue
gives you greater certainty
around your cash flow
and helps you forecast
your investment in Android.
And did you know that
subscriptions are actually
the fastest growing
business model in play?
You see the statistic here.
We had 2 and 1/2 times
growth in subscriptions
between 2013 and 2014.
And we think this is due
to a couple of factors.
The first factor is that
people are becoming more used
to paying.
And the second factor is
that leading developers,
like yourself, are improving
the quality of the applications
that you put on the Play Store.
So a big thanks to you.
A couple of case
studies I'll call out,
because I know I'm over
time, is that Busuu,
one of our good
partners, actually
has invested so much in
their Android application
over the last year.
And their focus has really been
about improving the onboarding
flow of users to sign
up to subscriptions.
And what they've done is they've
overhauled their design so
that users can really see
the value that they're
getting for signing up.
So there's a large
portion of free,
and then it's a
graduated call to action.
"New York Times"-- I have
to say this is fantastic--
but they were using a payroll,
and moved across to Google Play
billing.
And they actually reduced their
sign-up flow from two minutes
to three seconds.
And this speed of sign-up
has been due to the fact
that all the customers
signing up already
had a form of payment
on the Play Store.
And that resulted
in 125% increase
in subscription conversion.
So it takes a functionality to
build a successful subscription
business.
There's grace periods
to help people
who may be run out of-- there
might be a prepaid top up,
and their DCB, Direct Carrier
Billing, doesn't work.
Or it might be someone
who simply has not
paid their credit card bill.
So with grace periods, you
can give them a chance to fix
their form of payment, without
cancelling their subscription,
which works for the user,
and also works for you,
because you've got less churn.
Goodwill credits are really
great for rewarding people
who've done a good-- customers
who've given you good feedback.
And upgrades and downgrades
are one way to, again,
ease people up the
purchaser uphill journey.
And of course, this
is the one slide
I was really keen to
share with you today.
But I'm really,
really, really pleased
to announce that,
as of tomorrow,
we'll be launching quarterly
and six-monthly subscription
periods.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE]
And you can use these to do
many, many different things.
I mean, the first one is
psychological pricing.
So you can look at the way
that you price your packages,
and make it more
attractive for someone
to sign up to a six-monthly,
versus a quarterly.
And again, what we hope
to do is, in this way,
give you more flexibility on
your monetization options.
So thank you, very much.
I'm sorry I went
over, but I just
want to touch on the wrap
up, which is, number one,
Google Play is a growing market.
And I think we've touched
on that many times today.
Pricing is one lever
for monetization,
but quality is one of the
key elements to consider.
And you can achieve success by
following some best practices.
And please consider
the subscription models
that you can now use.
Thank you.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]